welcome welcome
a lot of big news a lot of stuff to talk
about even just since we finished the
show a few hours ago already sort of
like four major breaking stories I'll be
talking about all of them Donald Trump
has fired his national security adviser
HR McMaster Donald Trump restates that
he wants to testify or speak to rather
Robert Moeller Donald Trump's primary
personal attorney on the Trump Russia
investigation call it scandal whatever
has resigned and another I don't even
know what what term to use former
girlfriend a fair mistress of Donald
Trump's asserts that Donald Trump after
they had sexual relations tried to pay
her which sounds very very awkward and
we will be looking at all of those
stories in detail I now have the ability
which people seem to like last time to
actually show you the articles I'm
looking at as I discussed them people
seem to like that during the last
livestream so that's something that will
be going on we also will what else
should I do I guess I should just do
some very very brief livestream stuff
these this is a live stream this is
different from the broadcast show from
the studio and that it is actually alive
you can comment you can talk to me you
can ask questions etc etc you can use
super chat or scream labs comm slash the
david pakman show to ask questions and
send comments both are completely
acceptable methods of sending questions
and comments and I will read them if
it's a question I will answer it if it's
a comment I guess I'll react to it to
the extent that there's anything to
react to and then as always as I make a
habit of doing any new members and
patrons who sign up during the live
stream either at patreon.com slash david
pakman show or david pakman.com slash
membership I will thank you during the
stream and
we do accept cryptocurrency you can read
about that on our website people loving
that and please don't troll the live
chat I love this thing that happens in
the live chat where someone will like
paste a swastika or so or call me a Jew
[ __ ] and with in before I can even react
they've already been banned by one of
our moderators so they're our moderators
the moderators moderators have been
completely deputized and empowered to
get rid of people as they see fit based
on my guidelines and the guidelines are
what are the guidelines I think it's you
know it when you see it obvious trolling
will get you banned and less obvious
subtle trolling probably won't because
it's so subtle that we won't even notice
what it is that you are doing so let's
get right into Story number one why
don't we which is that Donald Trump now
is saying that he wants to testify in
Robert Muller's Russia investigation
let's take a look at this article from
the hill hopefully ten ads won't pop up
while I'm talking Trump said today he
wants to testify before special counsel
Robert Muller
yes I would like to he said this
happened after John Dowd resigned so I
think that there's actually some PR
value to this because the resignation of
John Dowd combined with the hiring
retaining the retention of a new lawyer
for Trump who has seen more as a type of
guy de Genovese his last name I forget
his first name who would try to push
Trump to fire Muller
this may be a way to indirectly say
listen if I was gonna fire molar and if
dad's resignation was an indication that
that's the direction I was going I
wouldn't be saying I want to testify but
that is the wrong analysis that assumes
that trumps motivation is not to alarm
people with the idea that he's going to
fire Muller I think a more likely
explanation is Trump does want to fire
Muller whether he ultimately will or
won't remains to be seen but the idea of
saying he wants to testify is so later
when he has fired Muller and people say
you clearly had it out for him from the
beginning Trump can say now
I'm on record March 22nd I said I want
to testify for Robert Muller and I meant
it why would I say that if I was just
planning to fire the guy I fired him
because he did something worthy of
firing so I think that's probably the
logic here as the article states Trump
and Dowd found themselves at odds over
how to handle the Russia probe and one
of their disputes was regarding a
potential Trump interview with Muller
president has publicly and privately
said he should sit down with the special
counsel while Dowd advised against it
Trump has long expressed the belief that
he should be able to deliver his
argument personally Tamala that his
campaign did not collude with Moscow's
election meddling efforts so this I mean
if that's if that's an accurate report
that just sort of shows the naivete I
guess I would say of Donald Trump where
Trump thinks that it's all going to be
did you collude with Russia did you
deliberately coordinate with them and
that that's going to be the focus but
the way that these interviews are going
to go and this is why I think Trump's
lawyers to the extent that they were
saying this are making the right move by
saying no no no don't go in and talk to
Muller because Trump's gonna go in there
and the questions aren't going to be mr.
Trump mr. president did you collude no
the questions are going to be super
specific about what Trump knew when
whether he had awareness of X Y or Z and
those are mostly going to be questions
that Muller's team already knows the
answers to because that's how these
investigators work so Trump's naivete
and thinking he'll just go in there and
swear up and down just like he
bamboozles and bullies people in his
business dealings he'll go in there and
just tell Mulder now there's there's no
collusion and Mulder will say oh you
know what I didn't see it that way
I guess you're right shouldn't really
worry about it that's the Trump naivete
as the article indicates some Trump
attorneys and outside legal experts
warned the president could expose
himself to tremendous legal risks if he
makes false statements during an
interview with Muller or his team of
investigators
Muller is also probing whether Trump
obstructed justice in his investigation
into Russian meddling his team
reportedly sent a list of questions to
Trump's lawyers that may come up in a
possible interview I actually I'm
against that
I think that's that's not a good idea I
think it's sort of what I do when we do
interviews and guests ask me for
questions and I say no I'm not I'm not
gonna give you the questions
but I'll let you know what the topics
are going to be I think that that would
have been a better approach but it might
might be something that molars team saw
is necessary the special can this is a
very interesting paragraph the special
counsels office is said to be focused on
the president's role in drafting a
misleading statement about Donald Trump
juniors meeting with a Russian lawyer at
Trump Tower in 2016 in June 2016 the
circumstances surrounding the meeting
and the firings of national security
adviser Michael Flynn and FBI director
James Comey yeah that's an interesting
note because it's long been suggested
that that is a direct way in which Trump
both was complicit in the lies
specifically related to Russia and it
casts a lot of doubt on the possibility
that Trump just knew nothing right I
mean like it's very very hard to believe
that Trump knew that Trump went from
knowing absolutely nothing about any
meeting whatsoever to sing let me get
personally involved in drafting the
response its most logical and again it's
not evidence of anything in and of
itself but it's most logical that this
is something Trump had a sort of general
awareness of and the participation in
that was part of Trump just thinking hey
I'm better than everybody else I know
what to say let me draft it and then
it's all just gonna be fantastic and
nobody's gonna have any questions
whatsoever of course didn't work out
that way right then didn't work out that
way whatsoever okay let me see if
there's anything else here in this
article I wanted to touch on Trump has
indicated he wants a more bare knuckled
approach towards Moeller under dad's
leadership his legal team largely
cooperated the president this week added
longtime Washington lawyer Joseph
digenova
to his legal team the Geneva has argued
the Russia probe is part of an FBI plot
to frame Trump and exonerate Hillary
Clinton so Trump now has a full-blown
conspiracy theorists working for him he
got rid of the lawyer who pretty astute
Lee came to the conclusion that Trump
shouldn't talk to Moeller from the point
of view of protecting his
got rid of that guy and instead brought
on a full-blown conspiracy theorists who
even used the term witch-hunt
the Muller probe which is a term that
Trump uses the Muller probe should never
have started in that there was no
collusion and there was no crime Trump
tweeted last weekend again calling the
investigation a witch-hunt doubt issued
a statement last weekend calling for an
end to molars investigation but then
gave conflicting accounts over whether
he was speaking on behalf of Trump or
just himself so we will see whether that
happens I think the most likely scenario
is not that Trump actually has any plan
of sitting down with Muller I think the
idea here is to portray a willingness to
sit down with Muller to later use it as
a defense for saying I didn't fire molar
because I was ideologically committed to
the idea of firing him I was more than
willing to speak to him I fired him
because he did X Y or Z and who knows
what that will be okay let's see what
else by the way is my video not doing
well because I'm getting a message here
from YouTube on the stream now that I'm
looking at it which says that there's a
problem with my keyframes and that as a
result people may have to buffer often
if you're having the buffer often let me
know in the chat and I can look at
changing some settings here you good
this is depth one anybody else am i
having rights okay from what I see
you're coming in clear video looks good
looks good to me looks fine to me looks
good to me
all right well I'm just gonna proceed I
will proceed as a Barack Obama once
asked Mitt Romney to please proceed
governor okay as I mentioned I do like
to do thank-yous and shout outs to
people who sign up or pledge on patreon
during the livestream and I want to do
that because we've got two new members a
Wilbur McGlynn has just signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership and
paul farrell paul farrell or ferrell yes
i'm not 100% sure how you pronounce your
last name but definitely Paul Paul I
feel good about
has just signed up and you can both
become a member or a patron patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
hit the orange become a patron button I
get pinged and then I thank you because
you did a really really great thing the
other possibility of course membership
we do have a 40% off coupon code for
membership if you go to david pakman.com
slash membership monthly membership
yearly membership your choice after you
pick one and hit the red signup button
this is the key you go down to the
coupon code field and you type vote soon
18 and regardless of which membership
you choose it could be monthly yearly it
could be 6 12 24 48 dollars a month
whatever you'll save 40% when you use
the coupon code vote soon 18 which is
it's a big thing it's a big thing all
the kids these days are doing it and I'm
excited to be able to tell you about it
today let me get to the next story for
today's livestream but before that I
want to get to a super chat because Troy
McCain Roy has sent a five Canadian
dollar super chat asking kind of
off-topic but have you ever been noticed
in public I have it happens pretty often
it probably happens I don't know maybe
maybe three times a month or something
like that it recently happened actually
getting on to the subway at the Downtown
Crossing stop here in Boston and as I
was walking by there was a actual subway
attendant we call it the T here in
Boston who said hey I said yeah I
figured there was something wrong with
my cart or he thought I was trying to
jump the turnstile and he said you look
exactly the same as you look on TV and I
said thank you
and and moved on cuz it is a little bit
awkward it's a little bit awkward every
time it happens but I do what I can with
it you know I can't can't always be
prepared with the right response
sometimes it's just a little bit awkward
okay I have already talked to you about
how Donald Trump says he wants to
testify before Robert Moeller now we are
going to get to the second big story
from today the story from earlier today
that Donald Trump stopped Russia lawyer
John
Daud resigned today very good Washington
Post article outlining the entire thing
and as it says president Trump whose top
attorney handling the Russia probe
resigned Thursday is struggling to find
top-notch defense lawyers willing to
represent him in the case according to
multiple Trump advisors familiar with
negotiations I love that because it's a
super subtle attack on Joseph digenova
Trump recently brought on a conspiracy
theorist lawyer Joseph digenova
who believes that actually the FBI is
trying to improve the public's image of
Hillary Clinton by even doing a trump
Russia investigation I love how by
saying that it's tough for Trump to find
top notch defense lawyers it's sort of
an indirect attack on digenova because
you just hired the genival but nobody
thinks he's exactly a top notch guy and
as we've covered before as the article
says some law firms have signaled that
they do not want the controversy of
representing a divisive and unpopular
president while others have told Trump
advisers they have clients with
conflicting interests there's another
problem here because prior attorneys
have said they don't want to work for
Trump because number one they don't
think he'll listen to them and number
two they're not sure that he'll pay them
so that act those are actually pretty
solid reasons not to represent somebody
and the what does this comment seems
unrelated comment from Japan about
national crises doubt has been the
president's main point of contact with
Muller's office which is investigating
Russian interference we know that Dowd
also had been negotiating the terms for
the president to sit for an interview
with Moeller's team as it examines
whether Trump has obstructed justice by
seeking to shut down the investigation
this is ultimately going to explode one
way or the other
and there are any number of different
ways that this could ultimately explode
but the way in which it explodes is sort
of going to be determined by Trump and
what I mean by that is that a lot of
what's even going on with Trump Russia
is self inflicted by Donald Trump if we
all just for a second take a step back
from the daily news of the Trump Russia
investigate
where it's one issue building on another
one building on another one and another
one Thanks step one by the way I'll get
to your super chat in a moment if from
the very beginning right go back all the
way to the beginning at this point if
from the beginning Trump had not tweeted
anything about Trump Russia not fired
anyone to try to obstruct an
investigation and simply when asked from
the beginning said only I respect the
FBI
I plan to cooperate fully I am going to
focus on pursuing the agenda I outlined
during my campaign while they do this
investigation I look forward to being
vindicated and cleared and being able to
move on beyond this and that's it it is
very difficult to imagine that the
investigation would have gotten to the
point that it is now and it's also
difficult to imagine that it would have
gotten as close to Trump as it is now
there is probably no way at this point
to really believe that there would have
been no investigation at all at least
into trump campaign associates because
even without Trump's statements there's
a lot of really sketchy stuff that
appears to have gone on but without
Trump calling even more attention to
himself and creating whole new lines of
inquiry about possible obstruction of
justice based on firings and so on and
so forth the degree to which this would
be hitting Trump would be a fraction of
what it is right now so I think that
mostly to blame here is Donald Trump
even if you believe that he was sort of
the pans the the Patsy or the the puppet
in the entire Russia thing that he
really wasn't directly involved he was
more the stooge who was being
manipulated it was some of his aides
that were more directly involved he
still has inflicted this upon himself by
the firings and the tweets and the
attacks and the war against the
intelligence community okay let's talk
now about oh let me get to these other
super chats DEP One has sent the $20
super chat saying you demand keep the
show keep the show going homie well I
planned you I plan to you though show
show is alive and well and it's going to
continue I think we also got oh
for stream labs.com slash the david
pakman show which is another way that
you can ask questions and make comments
- from Christina to dollar stream lapse
contributions from Christina David I've
missed you do you enjoy scented candles
I don't I hate scent scented candles and
in fact I recently threw some out that
were given to me as a gift because I
just can't stand the smell and I think I
might be almost mildly allergic to that
I just find it very very agitating and I
want nothing to do there will be no
scented candles here in my place to the
extent that I have a say alright so I
think we're more or less done I don't
know there's much else I want to say
about this Trump lawyer article oh this
is this is sort of relevant and I've
read a couple commentaries about this
Trump has this other lawyer named Ty
Cobb which is just kind of funny because
Ty Cobb was a very famous baseball
player and if you see the guy's mustache
it's also pretty funny Ty Cobb if Ty
Cobb is still there if Ty Cobb goes that
would really be a signal that Trump is
becoming more sort of I I guess I would
say committed to a more risque approach
when it comes to Trump Russia and Muller
and the entire thing because again Ty
Cobb has sort of been not that he's the
most reasonable guy but sort of a
moderating influence on Trump as well
okay nothing else to say there the next
big story is that Donald Trump has
indeed fired his national security
adviser HR McMaster now this would be
news already if this were only Trump's
first national security adviser but this
is already Trump's second national
security adviser remember the first one
Michael Flynn has already been indicted
and could really be facing some pretty
serious prison time I mean he has very
very serious charges against the middle
I I think come down mostly to what kind
of a deal he ultimately strikes with
prosecutors and with Robert Moeller's
team now Trump Trump had previously
replaced Flynn with HR McMaster a
again McMaster I hate to say it like
Tillerson not guys that I would
proactively say hey here's someone you
should consider for your administration
but in the context of the people working
for Trump Kellyanne Conway and Stephen
Miller formerly Steve ban and
scaramouche a Spicer
Sarah Huckabee Sanders McMaster and
Tillerson had sort of more more
reasonable heads on their shoulders so
to speak and now McMaster is going to go
and Crump tweeting earlier today I am
pleased to announce that effective on
April 9th Ambassador John Bolton will be
my new national security adviser I am
very thankful for the service of general
HR McMaster who has done an outstanding
job and will always remain my friend
there will be an official contact
handover on April 9th so again this is
not normal the idea is for every single
one of these to present it as though
these are just the natural herbs and
flows of an administration nothing to
see here it's all very very normal and
we shouldn't be concerned about chaos at
the White House but the truth is that
this is not normal the level of turnover
is within the cabinet has been greater
than what we've seen in a presidential
administration in over a hundred years
the number of unfilled positions that
are still going I mean it's just not
normal right and so we should all expect
number one that Bolton I don't know if
is the type of guy that will work with
Trump because if there's one thing I
find John Bolton's politics absolutely
disgusting and deplorable but if there's
one thing I think we can accurately say
about John Bolton is he says what's on
his mind
and that doesn't really work super well
with Donald Trump right and so I would
not at all be surprised if John Bolton's
tenure as national security adviser to
Trump does not last very very long but
we will see I mean the truth is that it
wouldn't be surprising if anyone's
tenure working for Donald Trump doesn't
last very long adjacent Brown 12 has
sent another super chat $5 super chat
hey David what do you think will happen
to daca is it dead no I don't think doc
dead and unless I missed some news today
the most recent news on Daka was that
because it's such a big thing that
affects so many people until the legal
challenges to the elimination of daca
are done they can't have they can't take
people off daca status or start
deporting daca recipients so adjacent
Brown 12 if I miss something today let
me know but I don't think daca is dead
and I'm obviously hopeful that
eventually something is done but it's
not it's gonna depend on people other
than Trump right because Trump has
basically taken four different positions
on daca even within like a 24 48 hour
period and it's not going to be Trump
that ultimately fixes it Brook Miller
also sent a $2 super chat Pakman we love
your show
keep it up man Thank You Brooke very
very much appreciate it of course super
chat & stream labs are the two ways that
you can ask questions and make comments
that I will read and respond to during
the live stream stream labs comm slash
the david pakman show link is in the
description for the live stream and on
that note I should probably I think
we've got a couple new members as well
and I've been talking about how I do try
I make an effort during the live streams
to thank people that sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership there's a
coupon code right now which will save
you 40% and that coupon code is vote
soon 18 and 2 more new members I want to
thank Katrine Miller thank you for
signing up and also Bob Parsons Bob
Parsons assigned up both taking
advantage of that 40% discount code very
very exciting
okay so we've dealt with Trump firing HR
McMaster we will cover that more on
subsequent live streams and programs
let's now talk about what's going on if
I can close out some ads that are
popping up there has now been another
Trump a fair mistress I don't know what
the right girlfriend I don't know what
the right term to use
and there's a New York Daily News
article which we're looking at this
relates to her interview that aired just
in the last hour I believe with Anderson
Cooper on CNN
her name is Karen McDougal she had some
very very interesting things to say to
Anderson Cooper and it's not getting any
better for a Donald Trump when it comes
to these stories an ex Playboy Playmate
who allegedly had an affair with Donald
Trump says he once tried paying her
after they had been intimate here's what
I don't understand okay if you were
intimate and then Trump offers you money
does that mean he doesn't think it was
very good does it mean he believed that
you were a prostitute does it mean that
he thought it was so good that he owed
you money like what what is the logic by
which after it's done does he do it just
as an insult of some kind to try to
degrade the woman I really don't know I
don't fully get it Karen McDougal who
filed a lawsuit this week to null an
illegal agreement that prevents her from
speaking publicly about the affair
publicly misspelled this is kind of a
weird article seems to have been
haphazardly thrown together about the
affair told CNN's Anderson Cooper in an
interview set to our Thursday night that
Trump tried handing her cash after a
tryst I don't even know how to describe
the look on my face she said it must
have been so sad because I never have
been offered money like that number one
and number two does he think I'm in this
for the money McDougal who's 46 years
old said according to an excerpt that's
been provided to the Daily News I looked
at him and said that's not me I'm not
that kind of girl
and he looked at me and said oh you're
really special I love that line
oh you're really special it must be so
rare that Trump doesn't have to pay
women for sex that he thought it was
special and particularly nice of her I
guess not to charge Trump I mean this is
just so bizarre
McDougal says the episode left her
heartbroken I got home and was crying a
lot I felt terrible about myself about
myself mcdougal filed a lawsuit Tuesday
charging that the Trump boosting
National Enquirer bought the rights to
the story about her affair for a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars but never
publish
that leaving her forced stay mute the
technique known in tabloid circles is
catch and kill has been used on a number
of occasions by the enquires parent
company American Media Inc according to
reports mcdougal alleges that Trump's
longtime attorney Michael Cohen was
involved in brokering the hush agreement
Trump's 10 month extramarital affair
with mcdougal came to an end in 2007
according to court records MacDougall's
lawsuit comes as pornstar stormy Daniels
is already battling Trump in court over
a nondisclosure agreement
she says should be nulled because he
never signed this now is getting to the
point where it's not really going to be
possible to ignore it indefinitely like
at some point it something more is going
to have to happen than just saying it's
all fake because it's clearly not all
fake right it's never random women that
have never had contact with Trump it's
always women that at some point if met
Donald Trump and of course Sarah
Huckabee Sanders will say Trump has met
thousands of people and has millions of
pictures with different people doesn't
mean anything else but it is notable
that it's never a woman that has no
connection to Trump like these are women
who are known to have had contact the
Trump at some point and they have the
legal documents right they have the
documents to show counsel that these
agreements are in place so the idea that
it's just all Liars at some point and
for most of the sane and reasonable
public it was a while ago it's not gonna
hold up anymore okay Depp one has sent a
four dollar super chat saying just
because Brooke Miller is awesome wow
that is interesting Brooke Miller
sending a two dollar super chat and now
Depp one sending a four dollar super
chat sort of in celebration yes of
Brooks super chat we have a five euro
super chat from Metro Young Seanie
saying David I politically identify as a
socialist but I do live in the more
leftist Europe do you think the u.s. can
ever have a socialist president uh
listen any predictions made more than a
few years out in most areas of life are
worthless I think it would be very
difficult to end up with a socialist
president in the United States of
I think that a social democrat more
along the lines of what we see in
Scandinavia in the Nordic countries in
some other countries in Europe would
probably be at least over the next 15 to
20 years sort of the most likely the the
furthest move to the left that we could
expect and even that is going to be
tough but no I I don't I mean in that in
the immediate political short and medium
term I don't think the United States is
gonna have a socialist president I think
what we what we could hope to have and
this is sort of my I'm not being a
socialist myself being US so more
someone in in line with the Scandinavian
social democracy model that's what I
would like to see and that's what I
think would be of great benefit to this
country over the long term Raul Aguilar
has sent a five-dollar super chat do you
think you would ever run for office if
so how would you make America great love
the show yeah I mean you know as many of
you know I was not born in the United
States so I actually could never be
President of the United States but I
don't really know that I'm interested in
running for office I think that there's
just a lot of I don't know I kind of
just like running it's kind of like what
Trump should have realized which is he's
way better off just running his business
and then he still gets attention but
he's not going to have all sorts of
problems that you create by being a
politician I kind of like just running
my private business and doing my thing
so I don't know that I would ever run
for office but wouldn't rule it out
certainly never president because I can
never be president David Trevino has
sent a $1 super chat with no question or
comment David really appreciate that
thank you very much and thanks to
everybody who's been contributing sharp
wit tube has sent a $2 super chat asking
do I think Trump will be impeached no I
don't I don't think Trump will be
impeached and that's not because I
believe there will never be an
impeachable offense attributed to Trump
necessarily it's more that I think if it
really gets to Trump at risk of
impeachment I actually do think he would
resign
and save some face that way I know not
everybody agrees with me on this there
are people who write to me every time I
say this is a no-no David you don't get
it
Trump actually would rather wait it out
and be impeached and then play the
witch-hunt card then to actually kind of
admit defeat and choose to get out
himself reasonable people can disagree I
think that if you were close to
impeachment that he would resign
DEP One has sent the $10 super chat
David can you do another show with that
Exorcist lady from the other day she was
quite interesting yeah here's actually
I'm glad you're mentioning that a really
weird thing happened when I interviewed
this Exorcist so-called Exorcist the
other day I don't know how many of you
are familiar with my views on
pseudoscience but I basically don't
believe any of it until I'm presented
with actual compelling evidence and I
interviewed a so-called real Exorcist
earlier this week and I thought I was
making it abundantly clear like clear as
glass that of course I think it's all
[ __ ] right and I asked questions
about how she came to believe that this
is what she does and how she believes
that it works and all of that stuff I
didn't yell at her I didn't say I think
you're an idiot because what's the point
of that right at any point I could just
say I am NOT going to move beyond this
last assertion and continue to push it
push it push it but that would make for
a pretty boring 20 minutes right so my
view is let's figure out why they think
this i'll ask my questions which make it
clear why i don't think that they are
right about what they're saying and then
we're gonna continue moving on but I've
got a bunch of emails from people saying
David what is this coast-to-coast am now
or ancient aliens or whatever like
you're now doing pseudoscience promotion
pieces and I don't know if I completely
miscalculated how I presented myself
during that interview but I don't know
how anyone could watch an interview
where I talk to a so-called Exorcist and
come away thinking that I believe that
does anything even remotely legit about
it I just have no idea and if it's if I
did something where I came off that way
I've got to rethink these interviews
because that that's horribly
embarrassing over it's stream' labs.com
slash the david pakman show Terry one
two three cent a five dollar contract
asking hey David do you think that
tariff has something to do with China's
recent change in Constitution and could
make President Xi president for life or
is it more of a diversion from the
Russia investigation I don't think it's
either I mean the announcement would
correct me if I'm wrong Terry but the
announcement of the tariffs was made
before I think unless I might have the
timing mixed up I think that was made
before we we saw that change to Chinese
law that makes it possible for president
for life to effectively be a thing in
China so I don't I don't know about that
I also don't think I mean listen Trump
sort of campaign I actually said this is
finally something Trump campaigned on
that he's just doing we can disagree
with the policy we can think it's bad
policy but Trump said that he was going
to do this that he was going to start
taxing putting tariffs on on certain
foreign imports or of course their
imports there of course they're foreign
if their imports and he actually did it
right so so I actually don't think it
was it was it was that in particular
okay let's see what else we've got here
Charmeleon sent the five dollar super
chat saying Shar slash Pakman 2020
alright as I said I can't run for
president how much money have you made
off you show all these years what's one
thing you like about Trump who is most
likely to be the nominee in 2020 we're a
private company we've got staff expenses
all that stuff I don't like most private
companies we don't make our balance
sheet public what is one thing I like
about Trump man I don't know what is
something I like about Trump oh I like
that he's willing to just go out there
with that hair and not try to do
something that looks a little bit more
reasonable like he's just he's existing
in the world and he seems unashamed
about just being out there and seen with
that hair of his and who do I think is
the most likely nominee in 2020 I have
made a decision I am NOT talking about
that until we get past the midterms
because I don't want to by talking about
2020 in any real
I am talking about an election that is
not the next election that people need
to vote it which is the 2018 midterm so
I'm not ready to talk about 2020
nominees Skelly crew has sent a five
Canadian dollar super chat saying have
some coins thanks very much
Frank McAvoy has sent the five dollar
super chat did I tell you Kellyanne
showed showed up at my parish for mass
six months ago I offered a user ten
dollars to hit her with the collection
basket she refused okay I mean that
sounds like it would be criminal so it's
probably good Frank that that she
refused Traci Benefield has sent a ten
dollar super chat I know Beto O'Rourke
is a long shot but if he succeeds in his
run what effect if any do you think
it'll have in the trajectory of
Democrats bid to turn over seats so
here's my thought on this Traci I've
talked about Beto or or again my
position has been yeah he's liberal but
he's not exactly a progressive hero but
he's running against Ted Cruz in Texas
so you're not probably going to do quite
so well with a super progressive and
today we did a story on the show that I
think is really relevant to your
question Tracy which is there's no one
strategy or tactic for taking out
incumbents what I mean by that is if you
are in a district where or in a state
where if we're talking about a senator
where there's like a very corporate
Democrat like the the uber example is
Joe Manchin in West Virginia who's I I
think I would say I think it's widely
known he's the most conservative
Democratic senator in the Senate this
strategy to take out Joe Manchin in West
Virginia did I say Virginia or West
Virginia I met West Virginia is
different than the one to take out a
Republican in a district in a state like
Texas and it's different than in for
example like a swing swing district or
something like that a new study was done
and it's a relatively small sample size
it only looked at 30 swing districts but
what it found is that actually in those
swing districts the Instinct often of
Democrats is to run very moderate
candidates like basically 1% to the left
I call it of the incumbent whether it's
a democrat or
Republican and what the study showed is
that actually Democrats would be far
better off running a more progressive
candidate as long as they're progressive
on the right issues so I think the
mistake Tracy is to think that any one
race tells us about the trajectory for
overturning seats in general what I do
think is a fair point is that if even in
Texas you're able to defeat an incumbent
Republican senator it paints a picture
that could be pretty good for Democrats
nationally but I think it's dangerous to
start falling sort of into that false
security and be sent a five-dollar super
jack
why is Trump setting tariffs who
benefits by the Brit boy Brooke Miller
and I watch your show every night
together she is awesome
does Depp one no my girlfriend uh-oh it
appears that MB is not pleased that Depp
one is sort of tipping in a way his
girlfriend via super chat so I hope that
that doesn't lead to some kind of
problem between viewers but I'll focus
on the economic question why is Trump
setting tariffs who benefits
so okay from the tariff itself the idea
is that the u.s. benefits right because
what you do is you make it more
expensive to get steel into an aluminum
from another country so American firms
instead of buying foreign steel and
aluminum they buy domestic steel and
aluminum domestic steel and aluminum
companies make more sales
everybody wins the problem is that we
don't exist in a vacuum right so as soon
as you put the tariffs on the foreign
country they can then put tariffs on
American goods so then you have American
companies that will suffer because our
goods become more expensive
elsewhere that's like one very simple
impact of these trade wars so in the
long-term usually nobody wins trade wars
and that's why so many economists are
against them Colin adder Lane sent a $2
super chat I'm sorry no I skipped over
one Dylan Collett sends a $2 super chat
how can we engage voters effectively for
the midterms I think here's the the
opportunity for the midterms right Trump
gets elected
wave of activism starts people that were
never involved in politics before are
all of a sudden involved in politics
we've got all the various marches you
can criticize individual marches for
applying the wrong tactics I've done it
etc etc but the good news is that you've
got all these new people that are
engaged politically the thing now is
just to turn out the vote from those
people we have such pathetically low
voter turnout in the United States that
you can win most elections by running
get out the vote whoever turns out the
vote has a really good shot of winning
because voter turnout is just so
pathetically low in the United States so
I think the most effective thing Dylan
is not convincing politically apathetic
people to become engaged in politics
take advantage of the fact that the
trump presidency has engaged so many new
people and you got to make damn sure
that they vote because I'm worried
especially in midterms where we see even
even pathetically lower turnout than in
general elections that voters just
aren't going to turnout so I would say
take all of the newly engaged citizens
and get them get them to vote call an
adder Lane sent a $2 Super chat Facebook
hires same forensics organization as
uber over Cambridge analytic ideas I
have no idea about that story is the let
me see if I can look it up
Facebook forensics uber and let's see
what comes up okay I've got an article
here from Business Insider Facebook just
hired straws Friedberg the same outside
investigator uber called on lost the
title due to an ADD uber called on
during its biggest controversy analytics
firm Cambridge analytic I obtained data
on millions of users Facebook asked
Cambridge analytic to delete it never
verified that they did in the Wigga
they're not bra or facebook promised to
find out if Cambridge analytical still
has the data and it hired straws
Friedberg the same investigator once
used by uber yeah I don't know in
particular what to make of that I don't
know much about these forensics type
companies so I'm really not sure what
to make of that Josh sent a five-dollar
super chat any idea how McMasters ouster
will affect the u.s. policy toward Iran
and North Korea I believe that it will
make it more belligerent I believe that
it will make it more belligerent and
there's a couple reasons to think that
number one we know that in the context
of the Trump administration which is
whacked that Tillerson and McMaster were
often moderating influences on Trump
particularly when it came to threats to
foreign countries we know that teller
cinnamon-apple at McMaster played key
roles in sort of scaling down the
threats and likelihood of an attack on
North Korea my presumption is that they
had or would if Trump got to the point
of looking at action in Iran so I
believe that McMasters ouster is going
to radicalize the position of the
administration towards Iran and North
Korea particularly as Donald Trump has
said he's looking at potentially undoing
elements of or all of the Iran deal
which could well serve as a pretext to
then do who knows what so I think that
that one's a pretty pretty concerning
one and I'm pretty worried about it
Jane womanpower has sent a five Canadian
dollar super chat adjacent Brown 12 has
sent a $10 super chat there is a law in
Texas called SB 4 it allows law
enforcement to ask for legal status and
Chiefs and officers who refused to
participate could face jail time
it is not getting much attention let me
look into that SB for Texas
[Music]
indeed yep I found that I've bookmarked
an article and I will look into that and
maybe cover it on the show thanks for
letting me know
greener thumbs sent to $5 super chats
saw your Alec Jones sticker clip how
long til he rages out and calls you a
globalist also please have professor
wolf on again soon capitalism sucks yeah
for people who don't know what greener
thumbs is talking about we have been
receiving a lot of pictures from viewers
who buy bumper stickers on our website
and then are using them to cover
Infowars bumper stickers all over the
country we had Ryan in Rochester New
York do it we had a whole bunch of
others I apologize Spencer did it in
Tennessee I believe and I've got
mother saved up already I apologize that
I haven't put all of them on air yet but
we're getting a little bit of a backlog
and apparently the Infowars black
bumper-sticker is the perfect size to be
just covered up super precisely with the
black david pakman show bumper-sticker
so there's a lot of that going around
and I I don't know if Alex Jones I don't
know the Alex Jones really cares maybe
someday he'll mention it maybe he won't
I'd be pretty funny if he did let me
pause from super chats to go over to
stream labs because I did get a stream
Labs contribution from q70 one for $10
who said this donation is for our hero
Pat go Pat alright there you go
very exciting Charmander char Mandor
cent a $2 super chap name one good thing
with one good thing Trump has done so
far no cop-outs okay Trump's tax bill
lowered the amount the threshold for
when medical expenses become deductible
I think that that's a good thing it was
way too high before so Trump's tax bill
to the extent that it was Trump's
lowered the threshold at which people
can start getting a deduction for
medical expenses and I think when we
have the corrupt and broken health
insurance system that we have that that
threshold should be very very low DEP
one with a fifty dollar super Chad
monstrous super chat asking just
wondering what are the benefits of
getting membership on your site David
that is a very very good question there
are any number of membership benefits
the most popular to membership benefits
are that you get daily audio and video
streams of the show with no commercials
right so the way that the YouTube
channel normally works is that we put
the show out in pod can audio podcast
form with commercials at 3:30 p.m. and
then the video clips start slowly being
released every 90 minutes at 4:30 p.m.
5 minute clip here 7 minute clip there
the most popular membership benefit is
that by four or 4:15 p.m. Eastern time
every day you've got the entire audio
show with no commercials available for
your listening pleasure but also on
YouTube we make full commercial free
video shows available that's the full
hour show instead of waiting until 9
p.m. and 10:30 p.m. and midnight for
individual clips to publish you get the
entire thing around 4:15 p.m. Eastern
Time that's really popular the other
thing is this the bonus show every day
we do our hour broadcast show but then
we've got an extra show every single day
just for our members and it's called the
bonus show people love it and you get it
every day when you are a member and as I
mentioned before right now on all
monthly and yearly memberships any
membership that you like you select it
on our website you hit the red signup
button and there's a coupon code that
will save you 40% and on page two you
type in vote soon 18 in the coupon code
field select your payment method and you
will save 40% for life that is for life
we don't say it's a low introductory
rate I'm not doing any of that stuff it
is 40% off for life if you don't need
the discount we of course appreciate it
if you pay full price right but if the
discount is omit makes a meaningful
difference to you please use it it's
available derek bus be sent to $5 super
chat how bad would it look if the next
administration decide to investigate
decides to investigate Trump's inner
circle for alleged crimes against the
United States in other words Eric Prince
I don't think it would look bad
how about it look if well who would it
look bad for I I think that that would
be great I mean any if there's an
investigation that if the facts and
evidence point us to needing to
investigate something then we should do
it there's never any shame in saying
we're not going to ignore problems
because of cronyism or for whatever
other reason right so I think that that
that would be a really good thing
Troy Mack and Roy or McHenry has sent a
to Canadian dollar super chat
what's your favorite genre of music I
don't really have a favorite genre
I don't like country country music is
what I would I dislike the most followed
by like really heavy heavy metal I just
I just don't like those but as far as
favorite rock genres it really varies I
grew up on a lot of like 90s alternative
the stuff you'd hear on the Sirius XM
station called lithium I think it's a
channel 34 grew up with a lot of older
rap Tupac etc I'm into a lot of Latin
American ska and reggae bands a lot of
Argentinian bands from my home country
of Argentina
Betty coast is one that I really like
ska Firdous there's just a ton of
different bands I love stuff like sting
and the police and Chili Peppers Billy
Joel I mean I don't know it's I really
don't like country music that's really I
think the big thing for me I just I
cannot stand it Charmander char Mandor
has sent another $2 super Chad how
embarrassed are you about your election
2016 prediction not at all I mean you
know but like half the country got it
wrong half the country thought Trump was
gonna win half the country thought
Hillary was gonna win saying I don't
know who's gonna win would be pretty
boring so everybody makes a prediction
it's now not really embarrassing and
it's it's not negatively affected the
show in any way in fact we've had since
that embarrassing prediction the show
has grown incredibly I mean by leaps and
bounds so I can't I can't say I'm too
embarrassed obviously I guess I would
have rather gotten it right although it
made made for some pretty pretty
interesting discussions over on stream
labs stream labs comm slash the david
pakman show purple haze oh nine cent the
five dollar comment with biden and trump
arguing like children and the actual
children in Florida and elsewhere acting
like mature adults with their efforts to
affect social change on gun reform is
this really where we are where kids act
like adults and vice versa yeah
basically yeah I mean I don't know what
other comment I can make as far as that
goes but yeah that's
so that's basically where we are and
it's disgusting it's embarrassing it's
oh and by the way I want to mention so
I'm gonna talk about this on tomorrow's
show at the top of the show but when so
Joe Biden at a rally against sexual
assault said something along the lines
of if I was in high school and someone
like Trump was harassing women I would
have basically beaten the guy up and
then Trump responded with something like
I could beat up Joe Biden type of thing
and a lot of people said it's the same
thing
Biden is threatening Trump and Trump is
threatening Biden I couldn't disagree
more
right Biden is saying based on the
things that Donald Trump has actually
said that he would stand up for women
right if women were in a position that
they were being victimized by someone
could be Trump could be anybody else Joe
Biden when he was in high school if
that's what that's when it was would
have stood up and would have fought the
person would have physically intervened
Trump is just responding by saying I
could beat you up Joe right so anybody
who says that there it's tit for tat and
they're both being equally childish give
me a break
there's this it's really popular now to
say oh everybody the left and right it's
all the same Democrat Ramon no but Joe
Biden was saying he would stand up for
women he would defend women he wouldn't
allow men to do the things that Trump
has bragged about doing and Biden
basically just said I could beat you up
right so that that's that there's no
similarity there and on that no I I kind
of wanted to just quickly look with you
if you would like to participate with me
at Donald Trump's Twitter feed and see
what's going on because I've I'm seeing
comments that he's off his rocker again
I guess I should look at tweets and
replies to see if he's been responding
to anybody so we've got the tweet about
firing mcmaster he retweeted charlie
Kirk who I guess interviewed him and
then it's seven hours ago as a candidate
I pledged that if elected I would use
every lawful tool to combat unfair trade
but but Baba and the related to the
tariff stuff retweeted Melania same
greetings from the White House and then
very early this morning remember when
they were saying during the
campaign that Donald Trump is giving
great speeches and drawing big crowds
but he's spending much less money and
not using social media as well as
crooked Hillary's large and highly
sophisticated staff while not saying
that anymore let's respond to this one
if the first part was a question it's
missing the question mark and no I don't
I don't think anybody was saying that
these responses I do to Trump oh and you
couldn't even see it cuz it was
off-screen I apologize when I respond to
Trump those tweets for some reason do
really well like I don't know how the
feed is optimized that people actually
see that but I start getting trolled
really aggressively like really really
really aggressively and then we've got
the crazy Joe Biden is trying to act
like a tough guy yeah so I'm not seeing
that much other crazy stuff from from
Trump on his Twitter feed today I don't
know what people were we're referring to
and believe me I am keeping a very very
close eye on that Trump Twitter feed
because it is it is just absolutely
wacky no question about that let's see
here okay
Cal Cal LM H sent a twenty Mexican
dollar super Chad what do you think
about justice Democrats yeah I wish I
knew why people were so fixated on my
opinion of justice Democrats I think
that it's a great thing to try to elect
more progressive candidates I don't
really follow their specific
endorsements closely this has nothing to
do with any kind of commentary on Genk
or Kyle neither of whom or even involved
with it anymore I just don't really
follow any group like justice Democrats
when T White's he had Wolfpack I wasn't
really following that I don't know if
that's still a right I just don't really
follow stuff like that so I don't really
just have I just don't have much to say
about it I feel like there's this
impression that I'm deliberately not
talking about it I just don't I don't
see anything that they do I don't get
any newsletters I don't know exactly who
they're supporting so I don't have too
much to say about it MB sent a $2 super
chat for hating country music and no
hate for Depp one absolutely no hey
for Depp 1 whatsoever DC sent to $5
super check been a member for about a
year now glad I found your program keep
up the good work
PS Pat is a shill for the Keurig
industrial complex hard to disagree with
that I'm very very hard to disagree
Charmander Charmander with a $2.00 super
check you had her at 3 to 2 lol why
should we trust your analysis I don't
know what this person is talking about
oh oh must oh I think this is the same
person who asked about if I'm
embarrassed about my prediction for 2016
I'm not telling you you should trust my
analysis I mean you know you can I
certainly don't think anybody should
trust my predictions and that's the
thing about politics that almost anyone
can make bad predictions or good
predictions and generally speaking
humans are really really bad at making
predictions but listen I'm not telling
you you should trust my analysis and in
fact if you don't trust it nobody's
forcing you to watch the show or
anything like that so so if you find
that I am untrustworthy in my analysis
by all means I'm sure there are other
programs that would fit the bill a
little bit more rbu eight three one four
five has sent a five Australian dollar
super Chad have you read the America
syndrome by Betsy Hartman gives a good
understanding of how awful people like
Trump gotta like that I haven't I'll
make a note to check it out getting
ready to order a bunch more books ba la
five nine eight four sent a five euro
super chat interested in interviewing
Andrew merav chic Princeton University
expert in EU US relations an interesting
guy I will make a note and look him up
always interested in interview ideas
Thank You Troy Mackin Roy or McHenry has
sent a $2 and Canadia to Canadian dollar
super chat have you ever been to Canada
I have I have been to Montreal more than
a dozen times one of my favorite places
in this region I guess I kind of live in
the same region it's only about a five
hour drive I have been to Toronto once
I've been to Ottawa once and I think
I've been to Calgary when I was
actually no no I haven't been to Calgary
but I love Montreal and I'm actually
gonna be up there in a few a few weeks
more like a couple months we'll be up in
Montreal with some friends and I just
love it love Montreal it's a good
opportunity for me to try to practice my
French even though almost immediately
anyone I'm speaking to just switches to
English and I have to sort of like
persevere and be determined to speak
French if I want to practice and it's a
nice mix if you know a Canadian city
with something a little more European
feeling great restaurants love going to
the IMAX theatre nothing really special
about it other than I just would always
go to that IMAX theatre as a kid growing
up go to the Atwater Market in Montreal
walk up to Mount Royal yeah love Canada
and but I know that some people will
hear me just talking about Montreal and
they'll say David you know that's not
it's not really Canada when we say that
when the non kept akua's say Canada they
mean Toronto or Vancouver or whatever
whatever else I will admit that I am
very French Canada centric with peace
and love I say that of course over at
Stream labs.com
/ the David Pakman show I've got a $5
comment from maitre de bas one who says
when are you going to put out an app for
your show love all you do yeah I keep
you know the app thing I don't know what
to do about the app we get pitched app
development just all the time all the
time and always there's something wrong
with the app that's being pitched and I
don't know that at this point I really
have the bandwidth to develop an app
from scratch and the show is on a lot of
apps already like run our channel is on
YouTube and YouTube has a nice app and
we're on a bunch of different podcast
apps like iTunes and iHeartRadio and
stitcher so I don't want to duplicate
the I feel like people who were
determined to use an app to interact
with the show probably already have one
of the apps that has show content on it
so would we really be bringing would we
really grow the audience with the app
or we just have a bunch of people who
switch from one app to another I don't
know I don't know I'm continuing to
think about it I I'm not against it I
think there's a lot to having our own
app maybe something in it to directly
call in when we're live or it could even
push notify you when we are taking live
calls or live streams that type of thing
direct link to leave a voicemail for the
show there's some some cool stuff that
we could do but just they're not sure
right now I'm still thinking about it
let me take a quick scan through the
non-super chat I like to do that as well
and see what interesting comments that
are there although there is a lot of
crazy crazy stuff typically in the
comments let's see here what do we have
any comments here a lot of people
arguing with each other I love how he
says it sharm ander instead of
charmander yeah i don't know why i'm
doing that i have no idea why i
pronounced it that way David would you
debate Kyle on Russia giving him that he
thinks there was no Russian meddling in
the election does he think that I mean
listen here's the thing people say Oh
debate Kyle debate Kyle bla bla bla bla
bla I don't know that there's really
anything to debate other than our
opinions as to how much of a big deal we
think Russia is and you know the the
truth of the matter is ultimately what
happened is something we're gonna learn
from Muller investigation so all we
would really be debating is saying
here's my opinion of how important this
issue is and he'd say well here's my
opinion and I think people think it
would be very interesting I think it'd
be incredibly boring but I also don't
think he thinks there's been no meddling
I just thought that he believed it
wasn't really a as big of a deal or
something like that but what do I know I
don't watch any shows what else do we
have here I'm just looking through the
regular chat to see what other questions
people have anything that I'm missing a
lot of people just arguing with each
other or if someone said there are no
Mexican dollars that's right it's
Mexican peso Mexican peso been a while
since I've been to Mexico last time I
was there I think it was 14 to 1 14
pesos to the dollar a lot of chat going
on here what do I disagree with oh these
people seem to be talking mostly to each
other which is great that's fine
I'm just not seeing a lot of questions
for me which is totally fine I don't
need questions there okay on that note
we've been chatting here for an hour and
I got a wrap-up big big day tomorrow
more shows more content all that stuff
thanks to everybody who joined me and
please please please do consider making
a pledge on patreon only a dollar is a
really great thing for us that's 12
bucks for the year and if just 1% of our
youtube following did that we'd be in
pretty damn good shape so check it out
patreon comment show I will stream again
that I promise you